bonjour à une rixe et casalino merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france le directeur général de la
santé jérôme seulement a répété hier que
le pic de l'épidémie n'était pas encore
passé au niveau national le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy estime louis je cite que
l'est vient de passer le cap et que je
le cite également sur la région
parisienne
on est probablement juste à la limite
votre réaction je pense que c'est ce que
nous constatons au quotidien dans nos
hôpitaux nous voyons encore beaucoup de
patients arrivés avec des formes de kobe
dans quelques-unes légères symptomatique
mais légères et d'autres avec des formes
plus sévères qui nécessitent malgré tout
une hospitalisation
il est vrai que nous constatons une
diminution dans le nombre de patients
globalement et dans le nombre de
patients qui ont besoin d'aller en
réanimation et c'est la preuve que du
virus circule encore dans la région
parisienne et que les régles de
confinement doivent être respectées par
nos concitoyens et que nous devons
rester très vigilants parce que il y a
toujours du virus qui circule plus de
7000 patients actuellement en
réanimation si ce nombre continue
d'augmenter le fait de moins en moins
vite depuis dimanche mais dans le même
temps la professeure les la boîte m'a
membre du conseil scientifique et
animatrice à l'hôpital bichat que vous
connaissez donc a déclaré à nos
confrères de france info je la cite nous
nous préparons à un jeudi noir et sport
ou pessimisme vous avez peur pour demain
non c'est pas forcément la date du jeudi
il faut dans le contexte qu'elle a dit
là je pense c'est que s'il y avait un
relâchement de la prévention cinq six
jours après on pourrait nous pourrions
constater et être confronté à un afflux
massif de patients le jour qu'elle a
fait les déclarations son compte les
sacs d'os à tomber sur le jeudi ce n'est
pas forcément ce jeudi là mais il est
vrai que s'il y avait un relâchement
dans les mesures de prévention dans le
confinement dans les quelques jours qui
suivent nous allons voir augmenter de
façon sensible le nombre de cas est
immédiatement le nombre de cas sévères
qui nécessitent des hospitalisations et
le nombre de
grave qui nécessite de la ventilation
mécanique le séjour en réanimation
c'est ça notre inquiétude comme soignant
non voyons la souffrance que s'impose
aux patients que d'être hospitalisé que
d'être dans une situation difficile
le séjour en réanimation est une épreuve
extrêmement sévère pour les patients qui
ont dû passer par cette expérience ne
voulons pas à revoir la quantité de
patients que nous avons vu je vous
rappelle que aujourd'hui nous sommes
encore à 2000 et quelques patients
ventilés en région parisienne ce qui
fait quand même grosso modo deux fois
notre capacité habituelle
ça veut dire que notre système a pu
répondre mais que si nous étions à
nouveau confronté à une nouvelle vague
notre capacité d'accueil est quand même
très diminuée et là par contre nous
serions ont très très grande difficulté
c'est la même chose pour les lits de
médecine
nous avons augmenté notre capacité de
lits de médecine orientée qu'au vide
mais actuellement nous sommes avec eux
je ne vais pas dire une saturation mais
beaucoup beaucoup de riz qui sont pris
et s'il y avait à nouveau un afflux
violent de patients nous serions à
nouveau et de façon très importante en
difficulté un mot sur les moyens dont
vous disposez actuellement à ce que
ils sont suffisants ce que vous avez été
réapprovisionnées je pense notamment aux
masques de protection gels hydro
alcooliques ou bien ce que vous êtes en
flux tendu nous sommes avec des circuits
logistiques qui restent contraints mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu' aucun soignant
de l'assistance publique en tout cas je
peux parler pour mon institution n'a été
contraint d'avoir à faire des soins sans
le matériel de sécurité tels que les
guidelines les recommandations les
précise les indics
aujourd'hui nous allons le nombre
suffisant de masse peu d'équipements de
sécurité pour le personnel et qui permet
de répondre aux anneaux deux ans p and o
deux impératifs d'une part garantir la
sécurité de nos patients et continuer à
les prendre en charge
d'autre part garanti la sécurité de
notre personnel est qu'il puisse
continuer à faire et assurer leur tâche
dans des bonnes conditions
vous parliez tout à l'heure de vos
services pour l'instant ça va mais s'il
ya un relâchement pour y avoir un risque
de saturation pour revenir sur le
respect du confinement est sûre même
peut-être le déconfinement on a entendu
le premier ministre edouard philippe
quirière qui n'est pas encore pour
demain mais certains experts disent
qu'il faudrait attendre que certaines
régions très impacté comme l'île de
france où comme le grand est et bien
voient leurs infrastructures
hospitalières revenir à la normale pour
ensuite opéré un déconfinement est ce
que c'est votre analyse également
je pense que c'est important de se
rendre compte que tout notre système
hospitalier actuellement est très
orientée qu'au vide ce qui veut dire que
la prise en charge d'un certain nombre
d'autres situations cliniques que le
concert la chirurgie du cancer
la prise en charge des pathologies
chroniques le l'hypertension le
cholestérol les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux les infarctus la chirurgie
programmée de multiples motifs
tout ça aujourd'hui elle dans la
difficulté ils étaient vivants que
progressivement nous devons resserrer re
ouvrir davantage de lits orienté à des
situations non coville que l'hélico vie
depuis ce progressivement diminués
d'être orienté sur d'autres pathologies
parce que nous devrons assurer la prise
en charge de tous les patients ont
toutes les situations cliniques qui se
présente au quotidien
aujourd'hui nous sommes très axés
qu'ovide parce que c'était la demande
d'eau principal et c'est ça qui nous a
permis de répondre assez vague mais nous
sommes encore pas dans un modèle de
vagues mais dans un modèle de vagues de
submersion sont fait une analogie à la
météo l'europe météorologie des grandes
marées le niveau de l'océan a augmenté
et nous sommes encore sous très forte
pression et passion coville qui sont
dans nos lits et des passions qu vidéo
qui continuent à arriver au quotidien
ces mots de la fin merci henrique
casalino d'avoir répondu à la question
je rappelle que vous êtes le chef du
service des urgences de l'hôpital bichat
à paris